welcome back we are so excited for the
first time I cannot believe that it's
we've been doing the show for almost
three years and this is the first time
that Reza Farahan has been on our show
I'm so excited that you are here I'm so
excited to be here number one I totally
know so many of your co-stars be on be
on the show and it was great but I've
been waiting for you I've been waiting
to come here first of all thank you for
the Gold Persian I love you because I
feel right at home yes we didn't realize
until you got here how Persian are said
actually very person totally I feel
right at home here you probably could
get anything out of me right now
it matches your six Cartier bracelets to
cardi a rings and gold Rolex
yes she's Cartier too by the way so you
are in town promoting new season of
Shahs of Sunset and premieres this
Sunday
I can't wait because for the first time
in a long time I feel like we got to see
a lot of stuff unravel in real life on
social media while you guys were off air
and now we're catching up between Tommy
vandalizing your house like there's so
much like the crazy thing was we were
off air but we were actually filming
right well you guys you guys saw it
online you might have heard a thing here
or there but you're actually you can now
unfortunately be able to see it play out
which is crazy to me and as far as I
know and I haven't seen any episodes but
this season really sadly chronicles like
the ending of your friendship with MJ
I mean it's sadly chronicles the demise
of our friendship and I pray to God that
it's not the end because how tragic
thirty years of friendship to end so I'm
praying to God that my heart heals more
Adams heart heals more MJ's heart heals
and Tommy's heart heals and at some
point we can start something new or from
the ground up something different where
we can coexist and be in each other's
lives because I truly do miss her do you
feel like there's hope you're sounding
optimistic yeah absolutely
why would I want someone who I loved for
30 years to not be a part of my life
anymore
yeah that's what's interesting I think
about chose a sunset when you compare it
to other reality shows it's one of the
very few shows where the history on the
show supersedes the seven years ago you
went to high school with her University
absolutely and that's why I think it
cuts deeper when things like this happen
I just a TV feud right look I feel
invested in your friendship with MJ
absolutely I feel invited my friendship
with MJ MJ has been a huge part of my
life she was the first person I spoke to
every single morning I texted her
throughout the day it's been an
adjustment not having her around and you
guys when we first started watching you
you guys work together - absolutely you
guys have been on the air for so long
this is the 8th season
8th season and it's been almost 10 years
it's such a good show I have been
watching since the beginning I am like
proselytizing to everyone that chousen
sunset is the best show on TV because
the reason you guys really do like love
each other there's a true foundation you
and Mike are such good friends real
friends
absolutely not TV friend not TV friends
and I just I think that it's so great
and we're opening ourselves up to new
people now we have destiny who I love
we have Nima who I really don't love but
it's exciting to see the past grow but
the mainstays like you and MJ are really
and Gigi like have really been there
from the beginning absolutely it's a
different show just like you said
because we were a part of each other's
lives before there was a show so we come
with so much history and so much invest
in each other's lives and we you know we
bring for the world to see for the
better or worse and unfortunately this
season yeah you see a lot of the worst
but there's good times too we do party
we do laughs we do get crazy but what I
think is cool about the show is that you
guys started at such different places in
your lives like everyone now is having
kids yes settling down and you got
married and you bought a house like you
still maintain that level of
entertainment while changing phases in
your lives
Gigi is pregnant right she is MJ just
had a baby she did everyone is moving on
up but the show isn't sacrificing its
entertainment quality no not at all and
you know I was this crazy and
interesting and dynamic before that was
the show and hopefully I will continue
you know to be this crazy and dynamic in
my old age and I mean this from you know
the most honest place in my heart after
eight seasons you don't even realize the
cameras are there when you're at an
event with your
friends and you're drinking and you're
socializing it's not like the camera
person is saying hey Reza look over here
you don't realize they're there anymore
at times I wish I had an awareness
because I might censor myself yeah and I
might save myself an embarrassing moment
or two but it's like it's not just a
reality show because to me it really
dives deep into so much more like a
culture that not a lot of people know
about and you guys are tackling issues
that like people in the news are
speaking of and they can't even like
have a civil discourse play you guys all
come from such the same background but
different life experiences but you're
traveling to Israel you're traveling to
Iran going sitting at the border like
it's actually an educational show
totally listen you know there was just
an incident where we attacked a
terrorist in Iraq and immediately my
social media was blowing up like Reza
what's your take on this current event
and you know obviously in my heart I may
look crazy and Persian and very ethnic
on the outside but on the inside I am
like America true baseball apple pie
maybe not so much like apple pie I kiss
the ground that I walk on and appreciate
this beautiful country where I actually
get to be Who I am so I am in support of
us defending ourselves and supporting
our troops and supporting decisions that
the government makes in our best
interests even though I was born in the
place you know in a different place
where it happened and I was
two-and-a-half when we left people think
oh I should be upset no like I'm an
American citizen
like I'm staying here like getting rid
of me I am here to stay did you go on
Bravo pride float I did what are you
responsible for some of the Instagram
content of all the Housewives fighting I
think you were in the car with them I
was like it was insane because we all on
Bravo shows have things that are only
things that as a family you know about
or as people that are cast mates on a
show know about that you don't share
with the outside world there's no way
the family totally and it was the one of
moments where more sharing than should
happen what's happening and I was trying
to shut it down as was Leeanne Locken
while my boo Kelly Dodd was recording
all of it but what an honor for you to
be in the presence of such iconic moment
such greatness and speaking of the gay
you know world Pride and being on the
Bravo float people asked me what was
that like and I said honestly it was
like riding a unicorn through heaven
like Andy was deejaying I not only am i
bravo Bravo liberty but I'm a huge Bravo
holic so for me it's like you know I
love being there but then I'm also
having fangirl moments and enjoying
everything that's happening yes he's so
exciting we always ask people who are
Bravo stars who come on the show if
their favorite part about being a Bravo
liberty is being able to go and watch
weapons live and I imagine that you have
the best time you're in New York
actually filming for this week's episode
I'm gonna be on watch what happens live
and I do love having you know my moments
there and I love being with guests that
pushed the envelope so like when you're
sitting next to someone who can also
push the envelope I've done it with like
me me I've done it with Kim Zolciak I've
done it with AUSA MJ Mike it's really
fun and I've done it with people like
Zachary Levi who literally at one point
I was like this was during the after
show but I went I don't know and it just
was like it wasn't the way watch what
happens live should be yeah since you're
such a Bravo Halle claudia was on TMZ
talking about her Mount Rushmore of
reality TV you were on hers I love it it
would be on your Mount Rushmore of
Bravo's stars Shin we're gonna bring it
full circle yeah okay so not just Bravo
that was so like any reality show can it
be past and present yes okay so if we're
doing non Bravo my first pick is Evelyn
Lozada
Evelyn Lozada is from Basketball Wives
okay she told Tony
Tami Roman that she was like that's the
first time I heard you're not um you're
not a [ __ ] you're a non
[ __ ] factor [ __ ] you're a non
mother so I would say Evelyn Lozada
Bethenny Frankel if we're keeping it
real messy I would have what's her name
Ramona Singer so she just gives you
those zingers from hell from hell better
like it's a Kodak we're having a Kodak
launch party and I'm Jill Zarin and
you're walking up to me telling me Kodak
is an antiquated company my endorsement
deal [ __ ] so Ramona Singer 100%
Bethenny Frankel Evelyn Lozada and
Dorinda oh wow thank you very robust -
yeah yeah um you just brought her up so
I have to ask you I'm not AUSA
yeah because to me one of the pinnacles
of like weirdness on the allottee TV was
one also like lied about how she was
like having a baby it was just so weird
and then you guys weren't as round like
she liked to set it like as if it was
fact but nobody even knew what she was
talking about and MJ was on the show
recently and I asked her if she ever met
AUSA's baby because we kind of we lost
awesome right after the baby we never
got on TV again and she said she hadn't
met the baby have you yes absolutely
the baby is friggin gorgeous he looks
like you he looks like a Cabbage Patch
doll
like he is so beautiful you think he's a
doll like you want to kiss him and
squeeze him his skin is perfect his hair
is perfect he's absolutely adorable so
I'm assuming even ASSA are on good terms
we are not on good terms I've spoken to
her in a while her and Adam fell out and
obviously Adam is everything my mate so
if you fall out without him you fall out
with me yeah you know I forget how many
stages of life we've been through with
you on Shahs you were single you were
married you paused the met wedding you
had a surprise wedding totally now
you're what like three years into being
married or yeah what's it like amazing
one of the side effects one of the
painful side I mean only out with MJ was
one of the most horrific things I've
ever gone through but one of the
positive side effects of it was that
very first phone call in the morning
- MJ that first text message - MJ has
now been replaced by text messages and
phone calls - Adam
yeah so I lost a best friend but it has
made my marriage a lot stronger and
hopefully you know when the day comes
because I want to be positive about it
where MJ is back in my life Adam and I
will be in a much better place than we
were right so in some ways that's a good
outlook some ways you think of it like
as it was meant to be almost I don't
even know if meant to be but if there's
a positive - sighs I want exactly like
can I take something like what's the
gift in this for me because I truly
believe good or bad everything in life
you might not realize it in the moment
but at some point there will be a gift
for you to grow from and work from yeah
I realize that all my questions for you
or like about the last eight years of
shots on Charlotte sunset because I
haven't spoken to you so I apologize if
I'm like I feel like I'm talking to a
friend I haven't seen in a long time
all these memories are not coming back
to me I remember a very important scene
seen a few seasons ago when you did
stand-up yes and I thought it was like
the bravest thing ever and I actually
remember being like wow that's not - not
only do stand-up like in front of your
friends and family for the first time
and then also do it on TV yes I remember
being like inspired by it and like
putting in the back of my mind like if
he can do it I can do it and I just
stand up to you now so I would love to
hear what that experience was like and
if you ever picked it back up because
you were really good at absolutely I've
done it several times I like hosting
more than I do
actually doing the set so I like being
the Steve Harvey of the Kings of Comedy
who comes out does a few minutes
introduces another comic just a few more
minutes and that goes back and forth
like I'd say yeah totally because I
don't have to have like a 30-minute set
but I love it and I feel like I'm more
of like a Kathy Griffin style comic
where I tell more stories as opposed to
like but um bombs you know actually
think that's like for me like a more
enjoyable style of comedy yeah because
I'm talking to you about like you know
the crazy [ __ ] like my family put me
through like when I went to get my first
facial when I was 16 years old and the
esthetician was like let me clean your
eyebrows and I used to have a full
unibrow and she literally took out like
three inches in the middle and I got
home and my mom
looked at me crazy and within five
minutes my sister was over there and she
came in the room and she's like listen
there's only two kinds of men in our
culture who wax the eyebrows
entertainers and homosexuals and I know
you're not an entertainer I was like 16
years old so go to your room take your
contact lenses out put your glasses on
because it'll cover that area and don't
come out of your room until your
eyebrows grow back oh my god yeah so I
tell stories like that and you have such
an interesting life experience that I
don't think a lot of people can relate
to
no half-jewish half-muslim all gay
Middle Eastern reality she led a country
reality star all that shocking
hair care guru Jerry Caroline your stars
of char star Shahs of Sunset you told me
you're still practicing real estate
absolutely never giving that up which is
so smart of you a long-term plan yes and
now hair got us Hey so does it be
obsessed kind of like me
my hair is very angry and unruly doesn't
like being told what to do
won't stay in one place for very long
and it's great you know maybe as a
characteristic of a human being but it's
not great for hair so I spent the better
part of my twenties relaxing and burning
my scalp to a crisp and I met this lady
who owns a factory fabulous she's
absolutely fabulous has developed many
lines and she's like you have great hair
would you ever consider and I was like
are you freaking kidding me we sat down
and we started talking and she's like if
you're willing to put your money where
your mouth is we can do something that
other people won't do which is put
ingredients in the cost of fortune like
diamonds which are great for shine
champagne which is amazing for shine
strawberry seed extract hydrolyzed pea
protein which is heat activated so if
you use a blow dryer curling iron flat
iron you actually release the beneficial
properties when you add the heat right
and we got to see you last season kind
of Chronicle this journey and you
started getting you know started on
formulas and stuff and you were really
open with the fact that you donate and
not donated and you used a hundred
thousand of your own dollars five
hundred thousand of my own five hundred
thousand oh my god Richard see me write
the check I took all the money out of my
retirement savings Wow
and bankrolled this haircare line
wouldn't people get it while we're
plugging you can go to resume obsessed
cause it smells so good I'm really
missing pomade in our hair before the
show always looks like we got diamond in
it okay yeah yeah go to Russia be
obsessed calm and we just did an Indy
Beauty Expo show in LA and we've talked
to a bunch of buyers and we're really
excited about being carried and some
very big that's exciting
name brand yeah thank you and I'm sure
we'll see more of it on absolutely okay
do you mind if I take some questions
from Instagram no let's do it
from concert gorillas what was your
favorite part of Bravo con my favorite
part of Bravo con is that moment where
like for example I wouldn't meet like a
Bravo Leben I'd be like oh my god and
then fans would meet me and they'd be
like oh my god so it was just that like
excitement full circle and interacting
with people that watch the show and
support us and just being with them and
taking a photo with them and just
hearing for two seconds how the show has
impacted their life or their brother
came out of the closet because they
watch jaws of sunset and they were able
to discuss homosexuality at the dinner
table because the mom and dad watched
the show and I'm like mind blown I'm
sure that people come up to you a lot
because you've been so open about your
sexuality your background and like how
sexuality and culture don't always mix
and I'm sure people like I've been very
impacted by her story and can totally
relate to how does it feel to have
someone come up to you and be like you
know you just being open about
everything you been through totally
changed my life so whenever someone you
know says Shaw's is my guilty pleasure
those people offset the guilty pleasure
element of it right so this season
you're gonna see me throw water in
someone's face and act a fool and say
things that I wish I could take back but
unfortunately I can't all of those
beautiful moments where sometimes I
share them privately because people are
DMing me or something all of those
beautiful moments offset the crazy so
when people are like oh my god you guys
are just a crazy reality show I think to
myself no booboo like you need
on my little like on the side I've got
this whole other thing going on there
were kids that I talked through high
school from the day the shop show
started from the time they were freshmen
until they graduated they're in college
now I gave some of them my cell phone
number they would hit me up when they
would have hard days I would talk them
off the ledge like I was able to impact
a lot of people in a positive way and
even just you sharing is impactful for a
lot of people and it's also quite
educational for McKenzie shraddh what is
one thing you would tell your season one
self don't read the negative comments
don't engage with the internet trolls
don't take any of it personally okay you
are also we totally forgot to mention
your mustache less yes if you've lost 50
pounds I've lost 15 lost 50 pounds [ __ ]
lost 50 pounds and kept the [ __ ] off
that's impressive and it chases me at
night like I dream about cookies and
cakes pies and [ __ ] and you also shaved
your moustache which must have been like
a really big deal for you because it's a
big deal for me shaving the mustache was
a really big deal because I realized
that it was like an ornament on my face
breaking up the fatness so it was like
you know fatness and fatness and fatness
and then there was the mustache so you
kind of like Streck how did distraction
and when I shaved it I was like oh [ __ ]
my face is plump am like I need to do
something and then just working out I
went to a nutritionist working like I
got on a program like I wanted to be
scientific about it
great so thank you I'm bushi broke do
you agree with you watch Real Housewives
of New Jersey right hell yes do you
agree with Jennifer from real houses of
New Jersey that Middle Eastern culture
is more open to talking about money and
it's not considered rude yes and no I
think you know my sister will ask me
like how much things like you know I'll
show up in like Gucci jogging suit with
Gucci shoes and my sister be like you
are a fool how much did you spend on
that outfit right and I'll tell her
but do I feel comfortable because I'm
Middle Eastern at me because I'm middle
Easterner asking
anyone I meet how much something costs
or how much money they have or if the
house is in their name or not no yeah I
don't
I thought she definitely crossed the
line she absolutely crossed over I'm
glad you agree
yeah so everything chop recipe obsessed
at resume obsessed calm although Reza
Farahan on Instagram for all updates
about Shahs of Sunset I'm so looking
forward to the season thank you for you
know sharing your life with the world
with me for eight wonderful years
hopefully another eight years I never
want this interview to end because I've
been waiting for so long thank you for
being so nice and pretty much for having
me you're hilarious
and I support you and I'm going to
resume obsessed calm to buy all the
products right fYI these are all for you
I'm not leaving with them I'm not going
because I got the whole collection for
free hahaha you suck you should go yeah
resume obsess calm thank you so much for
being here watch oz of sunset this
Sunday same time as the Oscar so it
looks like I'll be watching Shahs of
Sunset solely on Broadway I have a great
day you guys we'll see you tomorrow